hi this is presh talker in this video
we're going to discuss the math of how
size video gangnam style broke youtube's
counter
on google plus youtube shared a post
that size video
had over 2 billion 147 million 483
647 views
this somehow exceeded the limit for
32-bit integers and they said they were
going to upgrade to 64-bit integers so
that videos could have a lot more views
but what does all this mean
mathematically
we'll go back to decimal numbers
if you have a one digit number
that means you can have a number that
goes between zero and nine
two digit numbers have two different
places which means you can go to 99
and three digit numbers have three
places
since one digit numbers can go up to
nine that's mathematically equal to ten
raised to the power of one minus one
similarly two digit numbers
are as high as ten to the power of two
minus one and three digit numbers are
ten to the power of three minus one
now binary numbers instead of saying
digits we say bits because bit is a
combination of the words binary and
digit
in binary numbers you can have zero and
one
and you can either have one bit two bit
and three bit numbers
which can either be filled with zeros
and one
one bit numbers can go as high as one
which is two to the power of one minus
one
similarly two bit numbers can go as high
as two to the power of two minus one and
three bit numbers can go as high as
2 to the power of 3 minus 1.
so there's one more complication we want
to add that's for positive binary
numbers but if we want to have signed
binary numbers we need to leave one room
for a plus or a minus sign
which means we basically have to save
one of the bits
to have a plus or minus so we shift
everything down so two bit number will
be as high as two to the power of one
minus one and a three bit signed number
can be as high as two to the power of
two minus one
so when google is saying
they have 32-bit numbers that means they
can have a 32-bit signed number which
can go as high as 2 to the power of 31
minus 1
which is the number that size video
exceeded
they've now implemented a 64-bit signed
system for that the number of views
which means the videos can go as high as
2 to the power 63 minus 1 which is 9
quintillion 223 quadrillion 372 trillion
36 billion 854 million 775
807
if you look closely they forgot to
subtract the one
i hope you like this video please
subscribe to my channel
you can support me on patreon to get
exclusive rewards catch me on my blog
mindyourdecisions on twitter at
preshtalwalker and you can get my books
listed on my website